what is up everybody how's it going
happy Wednesday good morning hope
everyone is doing well you're halfway
through the week congratulations but
today we are gonna try to GTFO now if
you don't know what that is it's
literally the name of the game that
we're playing today it's called GTFO
it's a four person or four player FPS
survival horror game and you gotta like
work with your team and try to survive
obviously yeah so Ritchie's joining me
today Hey he's played a little bit of
this but you know fairly new to it as
well we sent out some invites this game
is on Steam only and then you can invite
people through their discord so you'll
notice oh actually you can because the
screen is in the way the cameras in the
way there we go so in the top right up
here
you see that it says the discord has an
external link you can go you can send
people invites so now we're just gonna
wait for some people to join up yeah we
got one it doesn't usually take long I
mean most people have probably moved on
away from the first level which is what
we're playing but we'll be fine we just
need a little little patience here yeah
getting through this first level was
very tough so we'll see how many people
are gonna come back to it but there's
always new players
I checked the discord just before this
end there's still people looking for it
just came out a couple days ago
yeah like officially released but it's
still early access it is yeah yeah so
although it did release it's still early
access which means more things are to
come and hopefully more you know more
players more people pick it up it's on
sale right now on Steam ten percent off
that's right
so yeah I think that's it's like $31.99
or something like that with the sale so
if you are interested once we happen to
a match you guys will probably decide
for yourselves or whether you like it or
not if you already have the game join up
yeah why not we use we can use two more
yeah
we've posted the invite to the discourse
server already just waiting on a few
more people we got Danny we do I can go
back and just post again if you want
just to bump up this see if anyone's
available then you guys can also get a
view of their discredit server lots of
people all the devs in there which is
pretty cool yeah there's already a lot
of - and this chat this discord chats
always going or the server's always
going so Becky and hopefully we get some
more people here seemed active seems
pretty active so yeah oh snap alright we
just need one more oh all right here we
go this is actually kind of exciting -
it's like he's good he's gonna accept
the girl
heyo they need a ready up as soon as
right there says they're not ready but
they're new I'm sure they haven't picked
up on that let me see here ready up and
then then it becomes yeah then I use
cool get to click this I think the name
is pretty funny yeah I don't know when
Chad says get the f out but I haven't
paid for it
but why I paid the rent yeah exactly you
deserves to be here is it PC only yes it
is yeah it is there's not even
controller support this game is like
purely PC all the way come on y'all
ready yeah ready up y'all we got to get
into the match I want you guys to see
it's a really good presentation it's
generally spooky kind of run me a saw
because you're like you're like a
there's like a warden that's like
dropping you into this underground base
to get information and you're completely
expendable so like if you die you die
but if they you get the info you get to
come back up alright just be one more
prisoner ready up yeah oh you can pick
your guns here I've had
despite all these big-ass guns I've had
the best luck with the revolver and
inches and the hand gun I think as I
spray to much like and I just waste
bullets so this kind of helped me helped
me out with that foam launcher stuff
yeah you have a lot of doors to
barricade and the foam launcher helps
seal it in this is my favorite though
just it just it's a little sentry just
does all the work for you very good okay
we're ready here we go guys let's do
exciting all right wish me luck this
game is so this is like a PvE game so
you and your squad you drop it in that's
pretty cool yes got to rely on the squad
that's me and my unit here and then you
get to see everyone else you drop into
it this will be a fun VR like an
experience like IRL yep rollercoaster
style here are the other three dudes
we're like strapped in ready to go down
it's pretty creepy
they react to light and sound listen to
that yeah melee weapons are best if
they're not on to you but the chat the
other day was like if the room goes
aggro Plus out the guns they will not
stop coming house volume level should be
bumped in a little bit a little bit yeah
it does get loud though so like this is
perfect right here here we are going
down oh the anticipation good right not
bad for a loading screen alright y'all
wish me luck
these guys are new I'm like I'm not
saying I'm carrying anyone I'm not the
best at this game but I have completed
this level once wish me like going want
to do the guidance I will knowledge is
power there we go
okay so our first mission here there are
boxes everywhere you get like ammo and
such and health boxes but our first
mission here is to get through this main
door which is guarded by car not guarded
but locked via keycard I go there's a
sometimes there's a no be careful don't
fall damage there is this just say like
it says it's a little yo I might start
taking the fall look at that proof that
there is fall damage I'm just impatient
oh my flash if you this flashlight is
very helpful but you got to turn it off
when you know there are enemies that
don't detect you then though wake up you
know they don't like lights and sound so
walking instead of running and melee is
key there's the door that needs the
keycard but there's also another door
with that we have to get through see
this yeah this game is PC only right now
because it just released on Steam but
it's still in early access even though
it just released I'm not sure if there's
any information about it coming to
console although it looks like a pretty
cool concept
something I could definitely see on a
convo oh I just need a second to regroup
my friends need to be oh shoot the door
can bust oh yeah so I blew it and ruined
the door
I blew it already hope you've been well
ah man I blew it that door it was like
we needed that door to stay closed
because we need to open this door and
the only way to open this door is to
sound the alarm and when you sound the
alarm
those little monsters come running in
from this door I can spit up really bad
already I'm gonna put down my sentry gun
and pray for the best
yeah man okay well my team's probably
get my team down there oh no they're all
right they're not yelling at me or
anything okay maybe they don't know
what's to come maybe yeah they'll start
to yell at me as soon as they know
what's up this guy knows what's up oh
snap Jake said are we playing where it's
elves you can join in a bit if we need
another hey yeah yeah heck yeah join up
I mean we do have three other people
that we found in the discord chat but
hey if this goes the way Trichy is
saying it's gonna go then will w have
another match
yeah it'd be nice to know someone who
knows what's up
cuz we're getting a lot of rookies which
makes sense this is the first level ok
the door is opening but I'm not gonna
open it yet cuz it helps to have a a
back here Oh No
as a big one that's other
this is a reminder I'm not a PC player
so
I'm getting cramps in my left arm from
using
not now right now but I did after
playing for hours the other day like
such a PC noob yeah you know this was a
matter of getting used to I always think
about the first time I really used it
like a guitar hero the heart try to use
my pinky on the orange the whole arm was
sore for like two or three days
oh I never use my pinky like that ever
right oh man
good times good times for sure okay so
we cleared the room we actually did it
yeah plus one now we can open this door
maybe going stealth with no flashlights
cuz I forget what's behind this door
there friendly fire I think so I'm sad
to say like I accidentally shot a guy
and there was a little logo with an X
through it that either means I hit him
and don't do that or you hit him and he
took damage and Emin sure yeah person
already thinks so far of the the
presentation no I like it so far it's
definitely pretty cool maybe you can get
in on a game if you want after this it's
basic controls if you have played a PC
I'm dying to try it out it definitely
looks nice there's one chilling yeah I
like this melee weapon because you can
shoot hey don't go crazy over there man
he fired one off it's okay you should
you sure who's gonna get my gun now they
saw us so
oh by the way these little ones do
believe in real life straight up the
only the little one what's going on oh
he got him okay
I was trying to say the melee weapon is
really cool and it works in stealth
situations but like you can hold down
the button and it for a more powerful
hit okay good work and it only takes one
of those to knock out the little Naruto
guys convenience yeah if you're stealthy
yeah but if you with it like I did
sometimes they wake up and they're like
huh then warms out for you
miner says just got here what's this
game about so this game is a four-player
FPS survival horror games like player
for everyone y'all they're just trying
to survive and as the title says you're
trying to GTFO and live yes oh you have
to I just would live okay you see even
the guys say don't wake them up so I'm
gonna try to charge up don't what he
still lived
okay we're good alright when the music
is your cue right now it just ended
which is good that means we're not on
high alert
but stealth is key for clearing rooms
for sure oh there's a big one over there
yo uh it's like reaching out for me bro
now they hear you if you run too much so
I don't have a like a foam grenade I'm
gonna try to figure out what to do here
well this is a fun part of the game my
whole crew is like stunned this is how I
was on day one someone's like what's the
move what's the move yeah waiting for
the team like where are we going shoot
okay I think I'm gonna go for it oh I
we weren't infected before
okay well I woke them up I'm gonna
switch to my gun city dirt it is
flashlight time did any of oh my god
that's amazing oh and the little ones
crawling around Jake said he's all set
up
he should friend on Steam Oh No we all
died that might be a perfect time for
you we all just died yeah and they
rubbing it in my face yeah return all
prisoners to the lobby
someone might leave and if so Jake we
will send you my discord number to get
into this Lobby if you'd like is there
difficulties
yeah there we go are you um let's see
Jake our number number yeah there we go
oh it's a long one
yeah just read it out to me okay one
zero nine seven seven five two four zero
nine eight six one seven four nine nine
eight that's if you want to join us Jake
we just put the code the invite code
into the chat and hey if anybody in chat
has a game and wants to join us this can
be played with chat but the chat is
serviced through discord like you just
there's a little chat room and you know
that's cool because you can even use
your mobile phone and get the app and
chat on there if you want but I like the
little type the type thing on the bottom
left you just type to your friends or
teammates
um just in case I didn't actually tag
there we go Oh Jake from the office Jake
we gotta get Jake in there yeah all
right cool cool cool check out the guns
here see what the other options are like
these do look cool and they like it just
didn't work for me as much as I wanted
it to all of these I tried all of these
this one yeah I felt like the assault
rifle would be my choice would you like
to try by the way you think are you down
sure yeah cool okay all right I am down
to try this out it's been a while as I
played a PC shooter that would be okay
yeah you'll be fine
amen says the game which looks really
good it plays smoothly it's just a
little tough again I have to emphasize
if you don't know what you're doing it's
your first time you kind of feel lost
like you feels like a maze for sure
but it gets better I played it all
afternoon I think on Monday I got my
yeah I got my feet wet and I got hit got
a got into a good Lobby and we completed
that first level there's so many cool
different things to use all right Jake
says what does he do with that code you
have to help him out Oh Jake there is a
I think you might have to I want you to
back out of this there's a it's it's a
it's a code to get into our lobby but
it's on the screen before this one like
you I see I see you take that code Jake
and then you copy it onto your just copy
it on Windows and then once you go into
this screen you'll see an option on the
left that said just join Richie's is
lobby or something like that it's in red
it's a little strange but once you get
oh we're on the first level by the way
Jake a one so when you click it click
into that you should see an option on
the left to join the server that's been
copied onto your Windows computer I
think it's in the screen before this but
we're since we're already in yeah we'll
have to make a new code if we go back
here yeah because we'd back out and
start a new lobby our friends here are
patient it's in your rundown so it's
this thing share lobby ID any prisoner
friend or not with your Lobby ID in
their clipboard can join through a
button that appears in their rundown so
the rundown looks like it's a peel
maybe next game it's done the one way
that's true we can repost it in the in
the discord if you want if well there's
also dilly on the stream so maybe Jake
just hasn't heard that for sure
info yeah shiny Falcon says when in
doubt don't punch the big ones that's
good to know
I wouldn't I took I got the hammer and I
was just trying to you know beat him
over the head with it but I'm just gonna
have to resist like running and gunning
a bajillion times
cuz that's you know my first reaction
Connor in the chat okay
Jake's got a ready up and then that'll
pop up for you purge they're ready to go
as soon as he does alright Jake is here
Jake works in our offices here yeah
wonderful cameraman editor Friday for
community Fridays I think that's right
you guys know Jake Pokemon all right
initiate let's do it
I got immediately nervous a second let
me it goes like control down here is
crouch and hold shift to run that's
about it Owen are of course reload you
got this Persia yeah I wonder how Jake
likes it
the meatrix in the chat says I farted
alright let's go
here we go
there are I believe five levels total
you guys this is the first one and it's
the one I'm most comfortable with that's
why we put it on and it's the only one
I've completed I haven't tried the other
ones yet but if we get good and finish
this one off maybe we can go to the next
level is really dark yeah so we turn
these on we can better already
from Pokemon to GTFO that's quite the
shift in game tone that's right Falcon
yes oh yes yep scroll through your
weapons you can also press the one
through four or whatever Jake we need
you bro were you I know Jake okay so
this guy to your left is like he's ready
to roll he knows what's up all right
we're following them then but yeah feel
free to good idea yeah look around it's
a pretty big first room sometimes I
think it's randomly generated sometimes
there are there have been enemies in
this room but they're just chillin
they're curled up until you find them
there we go oh there's one
of course that's probably go that's like
straight out of 490 that thing I hate
they're like resting soundly there's one
down there you got this though I don't
think I'm my team is all Jake doesn't
give a half he's going right for it
who's nice
Jake's back that one still asleep okay
okay they're so pretty much this [ __ ]
lips zero it's not really like halo and
it's first-person shooter but the tone
is different like survival horror and
they're really sensitive yeah oh boy
here we go
like IRL I know I should probably like
be cautious but everything in me is like
yeah imagine do it yeah that's exactly
the sentiment night I was like why don't
we just kill everything and then I got
murdered someone on the chat on the
bottom left there's in-game chat and the
first time I play this someone was like
oh my god it's like Dark Souls or SP fps
okay it might be too far but if you
don't know what you're doing and you
don't utilize your teammates you will
get like direct so we have to navigate
to zone 52 and find hsu eight eight
eight there are big labels all over the
walls that tell you like where you're at
so those are very helpful ah-ha-ha-ha we
made it
wait that's the one I believe that needs
a keycard
it'll tell you there you go yeah blue
three all right I can see why we need a
microphone so talks or its emails cuz I
could just be like somebody found a key
guard yeah what a geek our dad oh if
there is a map if you press tab I don't
know how I mean you have to like click
the scroll wheel to move up like it's
weirdly click yeah see there's that but
if you click the actual wheel and move
on
very good weird but I learned that kind
of the hard way
yeah I haven't found it what is that
little green square is that me
I feel like good question as soon as I
saw that I was like now I don't I don't
think I'm gonna be using the map very
much but I'm also that's like the
objective at least it's giving us time
to think right now it is okay I mean you
could do that that's not a door that's
gonna bust open but that gun that he's
using seals doors
jaylee asks can you revive a down player
yes you can you stay dead you don't die
out you don't bleed out you can just sit
there and wait to be revived unless your
whole team goes down okay that's the one
okay get ready Persia
that door behind you that one to your
left okay good it's closed
oh wait your friend needs to come in
he's gonna close it and just guard this
door but you actually I'm sorry for you
you need to be in that circle where the
guys are there we go
then it breaks up into four smaller
circles while this is going on yeah
there you go any one of those red
circles stand in and it's the final way
to unlock that door you're doing great
it's hard to concentrate I'm like
blabbing at you and you're like
murdering all these monsters
[Music]
Oh some a teammate love it there's one
particular style oh nice you got the
door open there was a there was no how
to explain it I didn't even realize so
I'm sorry
no this is like exactly iPhone when I
play like a cod zombies for the first
time one that's really complicated it's
like go to this door and then find this
thing it's all good it's all good
oh we need a fourth now yeah Jake is
still with us how did you like those
guns did you like your layout I
definitely like the shotgun that was
dope yeah I was trying to use this mine
thing but I realize I did not use it
mind deployer I haven't used that one
with that third one I think I'm gonna go
to this entry yeah that one you just
gotta look on the ground press E and
it'll little deploy very cool crime says
what's this the white lines all the
white lines that's that was a security
measure if you follow those white lines
on the ground it'll help unlock the door
all right should we get one more just go
three three people in let's do uh yeah
you're running it let's go will it give
us a buy it
nope okay
yep yeah shiny Falcon that zombie for it
is pretty much yeah that sums up that
part of the the mission zero hey what's
going on welcome to the chat joining us
today
dark minor yeah that'd be a fun gift
this game is only on Steam right now
it's tough but it's fun if you have the
right team and there's no controller and
support I know me and president will
meet you typically I'm a PC scrub and I
couldn't I got used to it but I'm more
comfortable with the controller
[Applause]
[Music]
denne have you played this game it's fun
so far glad you're joining us on the
stream today shining Falcon with all
right
if you ever want to chat with your
friends on the bottom left persia all
you have to do is press enter and then
start typing but
it's not 100% necessary unless someone's
like far away it's like yo get over here
Jake you might see it alright so where
do we go last thing to get the info one
of their several drawers is one of these
this looks that's it that's the security
door to your left the one that you got
to open to get yeah let's be running
this Shack says I'm too much of a punk
to play this but it looks fun glad
you're joining us maybe this is the way
to to get you know to check it out if if
it's not your bag or it's too scary
you're not your gun you're not good with
them scary games oh that guys when you
you can heal your friends and give them
mo and it's really funny because you
grab a health pack and you do this and
you have to stand in front of it and
then you're healed there's no like real
animation but if you see someone holding
up a box next to you they're trying to
give you something when will this come
out to console we don't know there
hasn't been any any news on that it's
only in early access on PC at this time
I looked at the steam page and the
official website there's nothing about
any future console release
hopefully it's doing well here close the
door and then I've activated it nice so
in theory that the door behind you is
the one that's gonna bust open oh that
way
I was like let me try this my Oh first
um sorry I had the camera angle all
wrong you were right I was looking at
tad evening prayers ignore me please I'm
trying to be conservative
last round I ran out really fast yeah
there are lockers with mo crates in them
but they're not that easy to find there
you go those white lines you did it so
that's a century gun did you all the
evening for me oh oh oh warmer oh my god
nope oh there you go
we'll jump in yeah those all right I
don't like that fail audio all right let
me rethink my your loadout there you go
hi ammo capacity I like the sound of
that
yep if anyone in our chat here wants to
join in and you have this game let us
know we'll drop it
our discord code and you can be our
fourth uh turrets don't hurt the
teammates and actually that's not true I
think I've been hit by a turtle for when
you walk in front of it it stops cuz it
like doesn't want to hear because I
noticed the light was like going from
green to red Oh like is that cuz I'm
running in front of it and I'm like
blocking and maybe I guess we don't have
a full and complete answer Shack but I
cuz I think I've been well yesterday I'm
sorry or the day before I think I got
hit by one my own should we go back into
the discrete and type of thing in there
sure how do I do I hit the Windows key
and then on the bottom I hit oh that's
already there great and then paste it
yeah a one yeah one for a one or
whatever you know we just need one
someone will show them there you go
cool yeah alright and now we wait now we
wait
I mean I'm sure if we can get past this
first level game looks oh it keeps you
on your toes right oh yeah we got a 430
but stick around we'll get to the Persia
can do it I have all the faith if I can
do it Persia can do it it took me a
while though
I can't say hey hey alright ready up
aspect just already there we go
Cheerios I made me I thought of Doritos
which now I'm hungry yeah alright yeah
this is the first level there are I
believe 5 or 6 and this is a one it's
called the admin get the revolver it's
ok ok see that's what I was rocking it
takes you know six shots it takes
forever to reload but it hits it packs a
punch
alright initiating the kids drop go
the dark souls of FPS huh yeah that we
heard that's what I heard yesterday
after a few games someone in my lobby
was like yeah this is a punishing Dark
Souls level
my character already sounds [ __ ] yeah
he's like breathing heavy I hate that
intro he is you pressed doesn't help
hazard exile if you want to jump into
the next game let us know well I have
the revolver now yeah big misses good
book no I know it was intro so char Jack
the story of this is you and three other
people drop down into these like
underground dwellings where all the
monsters are because there is a warden
who is like controlling this whole
operation and he is looking for
information he sends you down there to
find the information but there's
monsters everywhere if you can get the
information and GTFO you win but it's
you know you're expendable and you can
just die and it won't matter to the
warden at all so try to get the info and
GTFO try to survive that's it
oh hello there's one shilling
there you go you got there you go they
light up sometimes you can hear them but
not see them until they like light of it
and Ellie was barely visible yeah I kind
of seen them light up earlier but then
he didn't like mm room clear
intuition okay so someone in the chat
said lewd up and I guess that means I
can find some better leave maybe that's
why we're getting bodied we've included
up the loot they come in like little
toolboxes and lockers and they're both
Orange so they stand out but you get
health packs I know I thought that was
lewd to you get health packs and ammo
and tool updates I think I think that's
right maybe tool something I think it
just refills your tool which is your
century in this case oh there you go you
did that so smoothly remember when I
just jumped off and lost 8% of my health
okay we didn't need it
there's no there's a little mini oh no
cool sometimes these little loop box are
these little crates are locked and
there's a little cool there's a teeny
puzzle sometimes but that one was
unlocked
oh then I just unlock like a site for my
I was just mashing loot at some point
without actually reading what it was oh
I was scared there you go that guy's
sealing the door ah you use that gunk on
the door it really helps like it gives
you another like ten seconds on board
you're fine we're all setting up here
yeah if you want if y'all are ready you
got to hit that switch on the door and
then the alarm will go off yes Lee Levi
Teva teammates can revive but uh
oh never mind
all four of you know he's company's okay
I was like move
there you go now the security scan is
starting let's see what this revolver is
all about yeah how the guys too far out
yeah there's so many of them
Oh yep I think rules that always just
and like hello
okay the red moons of the earth
there you go you're all in the circle
the security beam yure is going up
securing the area
oh my gosh
that forth no you guys are all here
right buddy that fourth guy won't good
attempt are you survived through out of
oh I feel like we're dying at the same
exact moment
wait I'm gonna look at these there are
different melee weapons they all look
like they have the same person have you
filleted remnant from the ashes before
yes
Scott's asking if this is comparable to
a first-person first-person version of
that a little bit a little bit mm-hmm
got the seemed like you know same vibes
yeah same fight like creepy vibes you're
in like a little creepy underground
confined space definitely got the same
vibes
oh yeah shack that guy was huge I don't
like those tall ones they move slowly
and they have like things that come out
of their head whip yeah I hate that guy
and he sounds horrifying J Lee says damn
this game looks hard yep a little bit
but I think only because everyone's
still like getting the hang of it and
and you know learning like where to
stand and where to go you know what I
mean yeah crime says so you can win huh
yeah it's I've won once and then I
stopped playing cuz I was like oh I'm
done it's so satisfying it's a it's cool
when you do make it to the end but yeah
this game is winnable it's not just
endless oh yeah
well that guy was gonna hold down the
door so I'll keep the century there you
go utilizing uh yeah he's twisted
Joker's on him and he's like he's like
uh first of all being encouraging to our
friend here he's like don't worry it's
probably the first time we're all
learning and then he's like I'll
reinforce the door you guys set up the
turrets my man right there that's what I
that's I got into a lobby you
today with like three of those types of
guys and we just we just did it it was
we over communicated we stealth into
every room like if I can do it you can
do it perfect I believe if I gotta just
this I was like you go move my mouse am
i hitting the keyboard I'm like digital
soldier says my kinda game
thank you for joining us hopefully you
get a chance to play yourself I can
definitely feel like if I played this
with like three of my closest friends
overall just like communicating you're
like I'll be so fun it'll be cool field
like like chat with friends Lee this is
a good multiplayer game with friends
even if not I eventually found some
Connor says I got that that one time
nice me too just once
Figment back in the chat says good luck
thank you
you got this burger that's mostly what
this game consists of is like opening
those security doors and fighting off
waves until you can get around this hole
or lower the hole the whole building
down here I see it Scott there is a
story but it's pretty minimal it's kind
of like there's a warden that's sending
down prisoners to this underground area
in search of information and you're one
of the prisoners and if you find the
information you can leave and you live
but since you're expendable you can just
die and no one gives a F there's a
locker those uh they got um some good
loot sometimes
yeah that's fun it's like those games
you never win at like Dave & Buster's
you got a glow stick
if you chuck those in front of an enemy
horde they kind of just dodge around it
they they don't like take damage but
they they don't like them either it's
not like a pipe bomb they don't run no
no someone in the chat yesterday was
like those are kind of useless but I
don't really I don't really pick up
those glow sticks I'm really used them
Bob Jones I see someone else over here
maybe it's to guide them to run like in
here turret yeah maybe I just been using
them wrong yeah maybe though the little
like disorient them Oh and like keep
them away from your cool oh yeah we got
all the glow sticks now they're not
gonna know where to run shaq says must
be a big jail cuz dudes being died or
who's been dying down here a lot yeah
yeah there's a lot but they don't they
don't specify it like all right we ready
okay that was no no some guy yeah stay
in this circle wait for that security
meter up topside clear out and then
it'll break off into four small circles
go into those and then the door block
roll out take this five yeah
the door is open but if you like I said
if you open it more will come from
behind you so the best strategy I have
learned is to stay here hold it down
until the music stops oh no he opened it
oh no you got the right corner but [ __ ]
no
yeah
ooh oh no I gotta reload already they
don't see me on the fling
yeah they don't see that's great hit it
back to you see how they come from yeah
this is probably better so we have more
space actually oh no it would you okay
[Applause]
you're at 50% health you're good yet the
only reward for winning or lack is
opening up the next few levels I believe
there are five or six total I have a
further reaching flashlight now I think
I think I traded that for my glow sticks
which that's right you can only carry
one little secondary item like that I'm
here I'm here the music yes you can pick
that up and use it for later if it's all
as mo oh yeah you got 80% no 30% mo on
that thing
Shaq says this escalates so quickly it
does okay you may be doing it do some
Hales
oh gosh oh gosh oh you would've
guns-a-blazing oh gosh
yeah you guys got it here you know and
I'll be more useful with me sue says the
trailer looked better than then they saw
this game had so much hype for it I mean
we literally finally got past the very
first part of level 1 it's hard you're
ready to cash in those difficulty chips
it's a it's awesome it's all about trial
and error I've learned
Aylin Hill enemies sorry there weren't
many left I have hope twisted joke is
down oh no the only one up yeah oh snap
oh my gosh oh it's that one pesky one
that's lapis one or two that are like
just throwing fireballs it's so good to
see me hey what's up J okay under attack
alright see you don't bleed out I do
appreciate that
yeah coming from like a bit of mercy
right there yeah for real
all right when you prison oh goodness
you got a rate you got to raid those
lockers for some health packs yeah
a map here this room is clear though
thank God I mean why the zombies need
ammo not expect to find any ammo oh
there you go a little puzzle oh hey hey
watch out this is our loo I know
tool refill pack I think that I think
that's the one that resets your like
your sentry gun and gives it full ammo
Oh what did it do
no thank you no I don't know what that
does crap I thought I knew that one
[Music]
mainly doesn't run out right no maybe we
can research that was it called like to
Aretha okay yeah I just use on by didn't
notice anything significant mm-hmm
we are looking for a key it will be loot
boxes alright
oh yeah I remember that door in the
beginning that needs like the blue card
whew I haven't thought about that in a
while
[Music]
it's gotta be another
chats Wilin out they're like yo is this
a card game oh yeah absolutely
[Music]
why do you find ammo in this place it's
it doesn't come along often man it's so
scary if you hit up chat I've asked
before like anyone got ammo or whatever
health and they'll come to you if they
have it
[Music]
it's like left for dead but with more
gore I love love for day yeah oh dang it
oh you switched out your super powerful
flashlight yeah well we got the we got
the regular flashlight all right okay I
guess we can backtrack a little bit for
this key yeah you know it's not like
most games where the things you can
interact this will like glow or shine
you're like actually it's a go and
search for it yeah at least the lockers
have like a little green light on it
yeah anything orange my eyes are always
like huh like that guy was picking out a
locker but here he dips it he has help
if he's willing to share there you go ah
thanks Oh me cool you're back up to 40%
same thing goes with mo feels like an
ammo pack he just stands in front of you
and kind of awkwardly here you go that's
for you
what a pal what a pal oh I got some ammo
somewhere Hey
I don't know where but hey excuse me
all right so we're looking for
a card stolen right oh my gosh I'm sorry
cool sweet I'm also super viral maybe
it's a big map and yeah it's fine
so stood Joker's like meds anyone I got
you see I gotta have a homie like that
in your Lobby Denny in the chat says
this game looks very nice cool yes oh I
forgot you know there's a whole
staircase right there oh no I thought
it's this one does this one make a sound
it might not see the other one made a
sound right away I don't think this door
does that there you go it's open yeah
you know you know when you play way too
much effects and stuff it's like look
falling damage ya know there is
definitely there's punishing fall damage
in this game this is the little loot
room I remember now there's no bad guys
it's just a little tool boxes like this
good stuff good stuff
oh come on he'll come on mo wait oh you
already have one you just watch
rats do I know it like that really uh
scared for no reason
play too many spooky games with you
Richie good times yeah there's nothing
in here I think it is randomly generated
where they lay boxes hmm y'all got any
ammo how are you doing on able to see
your SMG is low that's half full that
your sentries at half percent that's
good and that's a girl like how do I get
ammo you don't just save it for when you
really need it oh yeah try to be stealth
and preserve ammo like really that's
that's what I've learned
wait this is like a dead end room after
you've explored this room and checked
all the lockers there's nothing else to
it it doesn't lead anywhere else I
believe okay
I think we done cleaned it out y'all
Jake is ready he's ready to move on I'm
not here oh oh there's a big one look at
that I think that's what Jake was trying
to point at you can ping things but I
don't know if he can ping enemies by
clicking the scroll wheel that was nasty
chat I know the in-game chat on the
bottom left that's where it's all it's
hot right now
I think he saw what we saw
goodness check yeah he took that for she
took that damage for just that little
fall crazy right it's game dis game is
oh oh you detected an enemy okay
someone did I hate that one
stop doing that I know that is real all
right what do we do shoot I mean that's
probably the way you just avoid him do
we stealth through this I think there
you go here's a pattern when he's
collapsed it's like that that's probably
the best way to hit him but if y'all got
the guts
that's to go downstairs sure why not
okay it's probably alien is down here
but those are quiet ones who someone
will come up oh you shot with the gun
[Music]
everyone didn't wait he running now
Baelor in the chances only a wheeeeel
game like roblox oh no Jake is down no
it's cool you got like the invisibility
cloak oh hey there's someone reviving
someone there's hope there's hope yes do
that creepy here we go run it's not
funny anymore no help is so scarce no we
went back for Jake is he the only one
alive wait F in the chat I was gonna say
that's great that's the longest you've
you guys have survived super scary
so is hello ding I don't think our teams
Oh Jake said peace the eff out so you
finished the first episode how far were
we you're from actually moving out I
would say like maybe like half there's a
lot of wandering that you that can't be
avoided if you don't know where you're
going and I didn't know where I was
going it took me one hour to complete
this with I see yeah and my final and
the one I did good games Jake
poor Jake yeah hey thanks for playing
with us do you know thanks for letting
me join yeah I didn't think that was a
that was too bad
yeah you did great you went from like
just that first day definitely not good
with the revolt various line go to like
this combat shotgun Peter yeah can't
join Peter you're correct they the
monsters are alerted by sounds light and
if you're running so vibrations yes
[Music]
super stealth stealth is key ID yeah but
but you know it's not always you know
you don't always can't always pull that
off
oh we lost him Joker no choice the
Joker's left I need you bruh are you in
a hockey me okay sure I did turn down
the sensitivity so oh for sure you Inc
whoops me my big-ass head would adjust
the headset accordingly yeah and I got
the hat on today okay I'm gonna send an
invite out back on the discord cease
copy this the invite systems a little
wacky but just it's so early access
exactly it's like primitive but it's
working and I feel super grassroots
which is kind of cool well yeah kind of
reminds me of like really old school
games me too for anyone there we go
and while we find a match I will be
right back
but okey dokey I'm hold it down yes
please do how we doing chat yes they are
Naruto running straight up it's a we got
to all right let's do this gang I gotta
tell him already up hey dudes ready up
all right we have D Rios from earlier
he's og he's hanging out with us
resident of kill no no crashes it's been
it's been very smooth that's great I
haven't even thought of that that's good
when you can't even when it doesn't even
come to your mind no there haven't been
any crashes overall the gameplay has
been smooth on a mechanical level
software level no no bugs no crashes
it's hard as nails but it's not because
you know software problems what the dude
left okay I need to send out an invite
once again if any of you in chat here
want to play let me know we had someone
earlier we had Jake earlier too oops
come on there we go
you won yeah yeah oh cool great we're
all here full Lobby is this coming to
console says sore thumbs
not that I know of not at this point I
looked on the steam page the official
website and there's no mmm indication
that it's planned for console they might
be testing the waters here on Steam it's
only steam right now in early access
it's very early so it could but at the
moment nothing has been announced
officially the rabbit man he needs to
ready up let's go okay oh no resident if
kill says so I don't know why but it
freezes on me hmm I've had no problems
maybe I need to internet here it's
pretty exceptional but I don't think
freezing up would be an Internet problem
sure
versus backyard we got a full Lobby
we're going down how's this sensitivity
cheating oh it's fine actually maybe a
little more how'd you do that
a little more yes your wimpy person
double bit president kill early access
bugs I guess he had some trouble playing
this you asked me if I've had any
trouble
TK gaming back in the chat what's up
okay there's three of my homies those
seats look pretty comfy though thank you
I just stay here well dirty but yeah a
lot has happened down here here we go
like why you got to get dropped off like
that though it's so dramatic I guess it
plays into the whole we're prisoners
thing yeah that's me feel like we're
some prisoners
we are Jim the stranger all right man
okay snoop around look for loot yeah
let's find some health yeah let's let's
stock up first hey pink something I
think maybe he didn't mean to he Rios oh
gee nothing here hmm there's that a
locker up there yeah looks like it oh
yeah
there we go see how it wasn't here last
my RNG is never good this is gonna be
the whole scream me just failing at this
okay did it yeah it would and then it
makes you open it with you okay
it's help let's go back in the game
clutch this this is the winner right
here okay it's crazy and press down down
that's what I tried yeah wait look
straight and then press down oh wow that
made all the difference
I just want to look at my feet purrs I
got the wrong guns I don't know oh okay
here them flashlights off no go wow
that's glowing there's a few in here
maybe I yeah like that just for a second
yeah there's one more for sure over here
I saw on Karen clicking creepy Oh eating
lunch this guy isn't handling it rabbit
man doesn't evolve oh come on okay you
don't want to hear that music okay we're
all here you sealed up the door did you
have a turret stone yes turret we got to
defend glee at the door all right wish
me luck with this gun I spray way too
much but I'm ready just burst it all
right
security engaged I think I mainly picked
it because it said hi and with capacity
and I was like that sounds useful
I love ya oh no I'm front row center
baby let's go
okay the doors unlock do they like to
roll no he'd be hated leave all right
we're holding it down I'm gonna back up
a little bit thanks for tuning in shock
I'll see you later
he's taking off all bye jack listen the
good stuff so far so good I've lost my
footing there boom boom goodness
[Applause]
I think I think I think we did it that
was easy
ha yeah I'm picking this up yeah well I
think some guy took some fall damage
that's okay
I'm not even Cap'n that was me earlier
let's go we did great on that door yeah
that was like the easiest run yet okay
anyone need help how are we doing you
can tell I think wrong one you can tell
their health are down the right looks
like Jim the homey that's you bro
oh you're hacking the locker ah ah oh
[ __ ] that's just I don't want to hack
your locker I want it because he's in
front of the line Jim Jim it's getting
what's Morris code for Jim we gonna kill
Jim I never did oh I just hacked him
wait Jim stay still he can't hear me Jim
David maybe I should typed him and chat
there you got him I tracked him down
success I am a Crouch here
mind you you're the only one who is a
hundred percent yeah survived that fight
without a scratch yeah that was that's
never happened here I left for dead
sure is the world ready yeah the world
now I would be super high for that
although I would get scared I think not
because it would be scary but because
the jump scare is just no no bounds in
VR mmm-hmm all right I'm going at this
so laughs y'all I can be stealth
I'm stealthy wait he said hold up 50c
come here I was trying to read the chat
on our screen - we don't need to go that
way okay oh yeah right there right there
turn the flashlight off rabbit man stop
there are grenades - they have those
like foam grenades but those are the
rarest ones I see well how do i attack
these guys he's actively moving oh he
said see the Strand is like touching you
you fine we'll go to that room later I
am all alone I don't have to change
they're all looking at me like what's
the haps what's the move what's the move
follow rabbit man apparently he knows
where he's going that's fine with me
this is yeah Jim didn't even think us
for healing him either I don't think he
noted this is the bonus room okay okay
open it up
I hope there's no bad guys in this room
like right yeah you know I try to
explain like some loom and yeah it's all
random but I don't I think this room is
always safe way to use my flashlight
this is safe
oh I'm going upstairs all right do I
keep my health pack ooh maybe go use the
health on some folks oh yeah
all right who needs how it looks like
the rabbit man needs it the most
this will be weird I'm just gonna run up
to him he's way up there I give the Jim
Jim Jim out of convenience I'm giving it
to you homey where do you go oh wait
didn't think my ammo pack you know what
whatever we're in this together he can
give me an ammo pack if I don't have it
equipped I bet
wait Jim stop chewing all right yeah
well six these are funny all right
think we swept this room have we all the
way oh okay sorry my sensitivity is
jarring I think that's it get out of
this room yeah we are yeah oh he said
med pack here Oh someone took it already
one more row back here right there's the
front door let's go I'll wait out here
for the team what is the mood
this map i've never really found a
hundred percent useful but i never
studied it there's a lot to look at it
door computer terminal oh that's cool
they tells you where these are that's
important Oh interesting
I see you like none of the okay I see
some ammo packs now they leave without
me it's flashlights like you so
sometimes the long-range flashlight is
dope but it takes an equipment slot away
from you like you can't hold a med pack
I know you can't hold like a grenade
instead or something cool alright grab a
man's on the computer check his Facebook
and stuff it's actually I think how you
find the information on the top left
like is is your like mission log like
what you're supposed to do and it
updates if you look at those computers
and tells you like where to go basically
so he's on it
IQ over there see oh no are we here
again look no one's here this time
upstairs I'm not gonna run empty I tried
to go down there last time but this is
where we're kind of split up
what's the chat saying did you find the
key no no progress has been made
hmm sorry I'm just taking these corners
very carefully right medpac yeah they're
finding all kinds of this is good we're
setting up we're setting up to win here
yeah oh my get both glowstick Oh shaking
then not stripping before alright let me
go down here carefully look no look
straight and then go down right yeah
yeah carefully like I've just used to a
controller you know me it's so foggy
down here okay someone's pants someone
was right earlier in chat like how
quickly this game escalates right now
it's so chill but once we do start
fighting it's gonna go crazy okay
there's nothing here oh my team is hella
far I'm gonna go find them see what's up
no I also don't like the full speed
running this is not that fast also and I
think they did that on purpose cuz I
can't just run away from my problems
oh no these stairs i straight-up jumped
off the second floor right next to the
staircase the realization didn't hit so
I turn around and saw the staircase was
there oh oh
shits about to go down friends according
to the rabid man thank you
okay so yeah I'm the stranger on the
bottom left there said he found the car
keys and now we're just playing defense
I will set up this turret right here
because that door gets crazy with bad
guys this our best run yet oh he's
trying to do that there there we go yeah
we need to get through here and this oh
maybe that door busts open - I know for
sure this one does oh good it's but it's
locked up - great great okay we're ready
we're all piling up here someone do it
not mean glows
Oh handsome huh it's a too late
all right ready enough of that okay the
security measures in place cleaned Oh
another another path okay oh this is so
much farther away oh my god oh come on
the scanner won't hurry up it's like the
movie like hurry up okay another scan
I'm just trying to find there you go
there you
yeah behind what he killed them for you
another skin you have a med pack I do
someone healed you I think sweet it's
done
no no the doors opens unlike the 500
they got stuck in the goop
alright the goo seems pretty okay this
will not stop good we did it we did it
taking this back so far so good guys
this is uh this is big Oh who needs help
I know we needs anymore
Cheerios needs it oh goodness alright
wait stay still absolutely still oh you
throw myself
oh no flashlights off hammer out come
out crouching skulls crush oh you blew
it
we can still keep itself if we kill him
now I think in that good good good good
good good anyone I don't like to overuse
the flashlight just to like yep my
corner I know I can you heard him
for in the room be careful Oh Jim
oh there's one there I blew it Oh God
look at my house my heart rate there oh
oh my goodness right goodbye
no thank you
no pressure okay what oh he is
downstairs I'm gonna let them handle it
I need to recoup here reload everything
my house okay that's basically what I
did on accident okay fault it for those
in Chad who have just joined us falling
damage is heavy in this game if I jump
down that little flight of stairs I
would have lost 10% you only have 26
health
y'all got any more that help yeah look T
Rios is asking oh he's got
a Mopac sea foam grenade glow sticks
wait rabbie man has a help packing I
need help
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right what's the next move are we
are we going through here you know
rabbit man yeah yeah that's that my
small boy thank you sir thank you sir
all right cool I thank him for that
thank T thanks this keyboard is so
sensitive
all right y'all next door are you ready
who's missing
you make sure everything is reloaded
wait no don't need to reload that or
that that's out okay already do it okay
the squad is still holding it down
pretty well yeah that's the only one in
this room
Zachary T says how is this game it's
it's pretty good so far yeah if you're
into co-op survival horror this is your
bag man it's hard though it's pretty
punishing you need a good team and you
need a lot of trial and error and
patience but if I can do it right what I
was doing we couldn't even give us the
first room the first time I played and
got into this room there were three of
them just like hanging out now there's
no one and it's creepy yeah exactly
no Locker up there maybe this room okay
getting my keys down I'm still a PC noob
very much so you opened the door and
there wasn't like ten of them right
there
yeah my friends doing oh they're piling
around a locker there Luton there's so
many things on the screen though says
goob yeah yeah this game is information
intensive but most of it like on the
bottom left that's just chat the top
rights my my HUD and top left is the
objective I kind of don't even pay
attention anymore maybe I should but
it's fine it doesn't feel like it's in
the way wait am I in this room already
yeah it feels like here maybe it just
looks similar yeah looks like the area
where ya were though geez
yeah okay okay stairs good this guy's
chillin that's where we yeah I came in
through this door
alright okay that's where we were
defending earlier I'm just going in
circles my very chest
unless we came full circle already right
we might have like on a remote open all
the doors yeah back
where are they let me catch up with them
they're kind of yeah Jim said more up
ahead where's Jim at I feel like I hear
my windbreakers yeah this a door no
Jim were you at he's down there okay see
this is what happened the other day I
still don't memorize exactly where to go
and that would make things faster but we
are all learning I mean I think about it
this is like real life mission this how
it would be it would be all running
around in circles like what are we
looking for
oh I remember now see the mission up top
says find a DNA sample and you have to
find it off one of these bodies and then
we do and then you have to run for your
life nice all right so let's find a
sample so any pile of cred on the floor
is what really important right
we found it once and it sucks because
all four of you have to be there to
diagnose it and like a security circle
opens and you have to be there just kind
of like help the doors work where is
this body though we'll see it's not on
the map good question good question yeah
might be too easy or source hydro system
no but it looked like this oh wait
they're freaking out about some door
don't don't
the doors bad news okay yeah turns out
she died okay all right are we doing
them sounds like they're still out the
door they don't want to go past oh
here's a nice pile here no I hear
beeping you too most to it it did
present him huh come on
huh we're just like good yeah yeah yeah
they're nice we're good that's what I
need to find a DNA sample that's that's
the only way I'm gonna do it I mean a
computer yes okay maybe the next room
have more guts are we doing this
maybe the guts are behind the door have
we been through this door yet does
anyone need mo badly asks don't want no
smoke I'm gonna close this door oh yes
the percentage in the middle on the
bottom there gube is my health oh we
have not opened this door yet Wow we
just walked right by it okay lots of X
good idea nice okay maybe I was remember
how I told you earlier how I thought you
use the glowsticks maybe this is
actually how you use it where my friends
go oh they're all there chicken [ __ ]
like me all right what's the chance that
flashlights off is mine on oh [ __ ] my
dad y'all okay check now there's no
other option guys this is the way this
is the way I'm not gonna face this one
because I'm too scared I'm gonna go
fight this little one in silence oh yeah
it's definitely
okay you should you should run no dammit
all right person I should have taken
your advice it's okay I feel like quad
might come for you I didn't see on the
bottom left there our friend the rabbit
man said there are 13 plus I don't know
about that but
oh they closed the door and left me in
here and like their pound now they're
pounding through the door I believe I
mean that'sthat's fine you can't bleed
out at least you took down like two of
them so now they got 11 to do if that's
true I don't know but I can see are they
down no it doesn't tell me a third down
oh they're moving they're all still
alive
yeah they closed the door and said see
you Ritchie meanwhile I'm like meanwhile
that's gonna wrap it up for our chances
um because yeah we don't know if our
teammates are gonna be at weight the
music is uh it died down
I think I'm I've been oh no oh do we do
we ride this out let's do it cuz after
the DNA thing that we find at the DNA
sample we run for the exit that's okay
yes let's keep going right let's rush I
wasn't sure if we were gonna survive
that turn this back on Oh Persians are
pulling the curtain down almost almost
our team made it through there better
than I know the team the squad squad I
want the real MVP you
everyone's like looking at all the guts
what the hell am i doing okay good guts
guts oh it made a ricochet job goofy I
already look at this I believe I've
gotta be careful cheese yeah there I'm
getting reprimanded in our little chat
here guys I went to a wall like we're
not wasting resources on you yeah to be
that's fair didn't even take out your
gun okay he pinged it I think wrong
we're all here ready to go someone open
the damn door yes II am Allah being the
Chinese you know what come on we're all
here I'm gonna do it ready flashlight
off they're like look Richie you can't
be doing that they closed the door on me
hey man that's the way isn't it were
they going
that's not we're gonna regroup here and
talk about what I did yeah we have to
take a moment here cheese cheese
word-for-word someone said that to me
the other day
they're like cheese like oh they heard
us what are you doing yeah nice one
well charged hammer shot from everyone
on the team clearly out of the room yeah
good okay I'm glad we didn't go that
other way this seems to be the right way
oh dear yes he was like I'm hurt pretty
bad I just have a stupid glow stick okay
now it's no guts no glory right
pretty much this is it oh my god I hope
we find it cuz that's the last thing to
do he had this I was getting no one no
one's moving up we're all scared
rightly so they're like here we go again
are you the guts I'm looking for there's
one over there
ping know wanted ping that bar
I won't let me ping enemies are you
backing me who's that oh this looks
promising oh my god so we needed you
lights off lights off throw some glow
sticks says oh yeah oh yeah what am i
doing so I think the glow sticks are
just so nice way to get some vision with
all having a flashlight without killing
your little pretty
more guts oh my god when are we gonna
find these guts this is a long Wow oh I
heard something there chilling they're
like they're looking at that other part
of the room maybe that's where they
excited over there maybe that's where
they want me to throw I won't run that's
where they want me to glow sticks I have
six left yeah look at that range
although there's like wow a one dork I
am oh there's a bad guy person they're
fighting him it's fine
I think meanwhile I'm scared stiff over
here lit the the Holloway though which
is good
I did where was I yeah yes oh they're
over there yes look for the guts fine
okay fine I'm going I'm going
whoa wait who me maybe our team doesn't
know we have to find guts
oh that's scare the [ __ ] out of me we
doing here this is the hallway late
wasn't it
no no no not at all those guys are up
that we're all just looking around here
okay yeah now it's a million hey have
you ran up there and get down then
they'll follow you up here where I was
law the glowstick town
no yeah we ran out of glue we don't got
the glow no mo the glow up is dead
come on how can I examine I feel like
I'm missing something here
oh wait what's chat saying nice job
everyone
laughing darn I thought you meant
something useful yeah I think is healing
you me what oh there's a health pack in
here you pinged it hello you need to I
need to take rabbit man Oh
navigate to zone 52 Peugeot if you want
to pull the plug that's okay either
we're close I we might but this is the
longest we've gone gotten into this
chapter so it's only right they still
Deary O's that we take advantage there
you go Dean wait what was that
I know I haven't been looking at guts
like I should be although I feel like
I've seen these already
navigate to zone 52 all right where that
doesn't say huh
no yeah it says over the UNC it's over
there bottom left
oh so it's in that room somewhere the
guts okay let's move move move
roll out room was this in here yeah wait
maybe that's all areas 52 wait go back
over here yeah and then turn left left
and then walk straight and then left
again Persia you genius way it might not
be you down there I was just like I
don't know if we went over here yet hmm
probably bid and although it's starting
to look the same the morning we run
right that's part of the the trouble
it's like have I been here there's a
there's a lot of backtracking was that
oh I got that was the command for the
door okay 52 okay why we're looking for
HSE oh wait someone found it no way
we're proceed to collect the DNA sample
we did find it okay awesome I was like
someone's gotta find it eventually all
four of us have to be here
Oh Persia I think this is it everything
I'm the gtfo all right I'm ready let's
go where's the exit return to the point
of entrance in zone 49 word alarms the
alarm is off I'm just I think this is us
know what assume it's where
the enemies are coming from obviously is
this a great way is it for my own good
oh my gosh are they following you and
you have no idea where you're going that
is correct I love it
okay nice nice this is full speed i
everyone's like running their own
direction oh boy yeah we got it we good
now do you have to defend for a little
bit
you'll drop that turret that's a highly
I don't know go let me get you girls
down
freezing them we all here
yes 50-person okay officially GTFO did
it
noise good stuff we GTFO daisy i love it
that's the new same she's it alright
good stuff good stuff it's actually
gonna wrap it up for our streams today
as well thank goodness you're here
achieve because when i say no you do not
work you did great you did great you
held it down for a long time but it's
super fun I definitely enjoyed it if you
enjoyed it it's on Steam now it is
actually ten percent off a nice little
sale going on it just dropped this week
so it's fairly new but it's still in
early access so go check it out join the
discord play some matches with some
friends and have fun until next time we
will see you guys later bye